la tuque remarquer qu'il est aux banques
le stress ne se lit pas encore tu veux
pouvoir me reprendre en quelques heures
et ce serait comme ça ok oui et non ça
ok
avec ce truc vainqueur ça fait vachement
gaffe tu prends sur le gâteau ce soit en
ce moment bon ça ça sur l'animal
elle ma jeunesse dans les bois j'ai été
élevée par une meute de loups allez vous
arrivez en même temps dans le rôle de
meylan tu vois gens vous venez deux buts
et quatre heures que vous est il arrivé
si brise un peu la gueule et on va
succès pour changer de costume trop vite
par des inserts on est un petit peu la
bourse a gagné du temps sur tout plan là
du coup l'enfant et argent c'est là ma
soeur c'est que à bas l'armée on est en
retard on aura du terminée depuis un
quart d'heure ouais mais voilà ça va on
va finir il reste plus que quatre plans
on attend on attend le costume de raf
raf arrive voilà donc ont marché deux
perdu un peu de sa indique as bien c'est
nul sinon bah non c'est my way
s'applique a dit fais tu vas en soit
l'on soit je pourrais fermer la gueule
mais je vais bientôt le communiqué je
promets que je pleure comme un joker
suivez cette voiture par contre j'ai pas
la carte bleue la bonne affaire est à
l'intérieur
tiré à ok une grosse résolution de mire
de fait n'a pas de tarifs d'ici veut
dire que monsieur mcneill ouais c'est
vrai j'aime les défis l'abandon tu vas
fermer ta gueule et rendez vous tout le
monde police de new york
l'hôtel je peux marcher un peu j'ai
entendu j'ai entendu un loup